that scream you're hearing in this one
moment from venom that's not tom hardy
that's scott white scream artists are
some of hollywood's best kept secrets
like actually secret take ashley pelden
she's one of the most accomplished
screamers in hollywood but you might not
know where to find her as productions
don't always want audiences to know that
their stars have been dubbed
this makes nailing both the emotion and
the actor's voice that much more
important here's how they get the
perfect
i'm sure i blasted you guys
a lot of the sounds captured on set
aren't actually usable so they have to
be re-recorded later the great uh
background actors who are there on set
that day who probably weren't miked or
maybe there's too much going on in the
noise they'll have wind machines going
and sound effects or you'll have like
the stunt man or the director yelling at
the actors but when it comes to screams
sound quality is just one factor screams
are physically difficult just look at
this clip of hugh jackman dubbing some
of his noises from logan
so if an actor wants to keep their voice
intact these skilled recording artists
can help you know maybe i'm more
expendable because for a session fee i
can blow out my voice helden and white
first need to know what type of screen
they're doing as that will impact their
performance one of the most common
screams you'll see in movies are fearful
ones but they're not actually realistic
now what's interesting is in real life
most people will probably freeze up and
not a lot of sound comes out but it's
not as dramatic on screen so we want to
make sure that it's a big loud
terrifying screen determining where in
the body fear comes from can make the
scream more believable peldon says fear
screams should feel involuntary even if
they aren't so she puts her diaphragm to
work you want it as messy as possible to
get it the most realistic so like if you
hear just a
you know really clean short or contained
kind of scream it's not really as
realistic for somebody who's in a lot of
fear but if somebody is fearing for
their life or in a really terrifying
situation it's got the adrenaline
pumping it's got the sweat it's got the
movement so it's going to be more of a
kind of a feel scream you can see and
hear this as peld and watches an old
horror clip where it's the building
tension is what's important there this
one to me would feel more of a
fear
building kind of scream rather than a
blood curdling scream but what makes
that scream
[Applause]
sound different from this one
rage is the motion of anger right so
it's it's screaming with the intention
of penned up emotions you need to let it
out screams that come from a place of
anger call for a clenched mouth and
tighter body position and a more
empowering rage scream calls for peldon
to fully open her mouth
white will do the same when recording
war cries for games like call of duty
for other roles peldon will channel
grief so grief has a different feel
because this is pure pain but not
physical pain right this is just
emotional pain i i tend to think of this
as the most uncontained and unhinged
kind of feeling when sinking to a clip
she'll often need to give multiple
options
this is a no she's saying
listen if she tries one scream with the
word no
and one without
convincing screams involve much more
than just incorporating dialogue
listen to all the extra pants and
breaths white adds to his screams during
a fight scene from the video game days
gone
these wordless physical reactions are
called efforts and they're crucial to
fight screams it's different than when
it's a scream of fear that's more of a
pull in sensation usually these are more
of a push out kind of sensation there's
an impact attached each breath and grunt
will have subtle differences based on
the type of distress their characters
experience a gut shot would knock the
wind out of you which is more of a
face punch would be more of a quick
strike
well this effort
fits in perfectly when white's character
delivers a kick this one
matches when he swings a machete
all these variations help keep the scene
alive all of the energy when the
camera's not on my character to keep
that character going in the background
but some screams don't fit neatly into
one category
for example in incredibles 2 white had
to create the scream for a pilot who's
thrown out of a helicopter the fear of
being pushed out of the helicopter which
then turns into anger like ah
i shouldn't have been kicked out of that
plane you know or whatever so it
couldn't just be as fierce
and then you hit the water it had to
have a little two-part act and once you
hit water
you're not going to hear any more of the
ah
you don't hear the arc of the voice
this process gets even trickier when
scream artists dub for a high profile
actor like white did for tom hardy
during the motorcycle chase in venom
white first needed to study the actor's
voice to figure out what makes it unique
so tom hardy has sort of a gruff sort of
a lower sort of a voice thing so i knew
going in that it had to be have a little
more grit to the voice next he did
what's called chasing the scene where he
watches the sequence from start to
finish adding all screams and efforts as
the scene progresses
[Music]
cut two now this is when you breathe and
don't pass out feeling a little
lightheaded but you push through back to
it
and you can tell it's a workout one
short few minutes seen in and i'm
already sweating bullets after that
breather white looked for specifics
we're really trying to hone in on the
actual stream itself and analyze the
screen like when an explosion goes off
behind hardy he's got his closed mouth
and his teeth are showing and so you
have to yell through your teeth to match
that performance
then when hardy flies off his motorcycle
white had to sustain a scream for nearly
10 seconds without losing the imitation
of hardy's voice the art of a long
screen is to kind of tighten your vocal
folds just enough and release just
enough air that you can prolong that
scream as long as people need when you
do that you're kind of tightening your
stomach
while
again tom hardy's voice is more gritty
or lower so you kind of have to get that
gravelly thing in your scream
while you're pinching your um vocal
folds and tightening your diaphragm just
to get out enough air because if you're
pushing too much air you're going to run
out of air
all of these screams whether their fear
rage or fighting sounds won't carry the
same emotional punch until they've gone
through a layering process those layers
can include the actors real vocals mixed
with the dubbed vocals and digital
sounds layering is especially helpful
for non-human voices like when white
performed the otherworldly screams of
the demon from the conjuring the devil
made me do it
[Applause]
here's a demonstration of how a sound
mixer might take white's raw screams and
add effects to make them more powerful
listen to these three elements combined
in a scene
creepy right well adding effects like
reverb to create an echo and a rumble
can make them even scarier
you know
using what the human body can do and
then taking effects
you know putting it all in the melting
pot these clips don't seem as exciting
frightening or sad until a scream
artist's work is added to it
so what makes one of peldon's real
screams
sound better than this one
i think what makes the difference
between what sounds kind of like a
generic screen that they could just get
from their library of screams versus one
that really fits the scene is matching
what we're seeing the actor the energy
the emotion my scream isn't just
noise it's an acting burst six screams
two seconds each go give us options
you know and you just and then they'll
then they'll grab each of those files
and use them all in different places of
the game so